c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public direction le Liban depuis
l'assassinat le 2 janvier par Israël du
numéro 2 du ramas à Beyrouth la crainte
de voir la guerre s'étendre à ce pays
est palpable hier encore un haut
commandant du Hezbollah a été éliminé
par l'armée israélienne l'allié libanais
du Hamas a répondu en ciblant un centre
de commandement de tsal Cécile
Sixou sur ces images une frappe
israélienne lundi soir au sud du Liban
elle tue trois membres du Hezbollah des
chefs militaires de premier plan dont
issamassan Tail sur cette photo brandie
par des militants du mouvement islamiste
lors de ces funérailles laaripost n'a
pas tardé le lendemain le hzbolah frappe
à son tour et cible un centre de
commandement de l'armée israélienne dans
le nord du pays une escalade de violence
une montée des tensions à la frontière
libanaise et la crainte désormais d'un
embrasement régional de la guerre entre
Israël et le Hamas mais pour Frédéric
Ansel géopolitologue si le hzbolah est
un allié du Hamas il n'a pas l'ambition
d'entrer en conflit avec Israël
risbollah a un agenda très clair c'est
la vampirisation du Liban c'est le
soutien le la poursuite du soutien
militaire à Bachar al-Assad en Syrie et
certainement pas le ramas donc le
risbollah se caractérise par le fait
qu'il est dirigé par des fanatiques mais
pas par des imbéciles et les rapports de
force il les connaît très bien la raison
pour laquelle je pense que le risbolla
n'entrera pas frontalement massivement
en guerre avec Israël ces nouvelles
tensions interviennent en tout cas au
moment même où les États-Unis tentent de
calmer le jeu le chef de la diplomatie
Anthony blinken sillonne depuis 4 jours
le Moyen-Orient avec un
message comme nous l'avons dit dès le
premier jour nous nous efforçons
d'empêcher que ce conflit ne s'étende
Anthony blinken continue son marathon
diplomatique aujourd'hui à Bahrain avant
de se rendre en
Égypte le Liban est-il aux portes de la
guerre en en débat avec Aurélie daer
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes enseignante
chercheuse à l'Université Paris Dauphine
et à Scien Paris et vous publiez le
hzbollah mobilisation et pouvoir au
presse universitaire de France David
rigoler rose bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes chercheur à l'Institut français
d'analyse stratégique chercheur associé
à Liris et rédacteur en chef de la revue
Orient stratégique le dernier numéro
d'ailleurs s'intitule Liban polycrise et
menaces existentielles Armel charier
bonsoir bienvenue éitoraliste
international à FRANCE 24 vous êtes
spécialiste en géopolitique stratégie et
défense et Mathieu croissant d'itor
politique est resté à mes côtés euh je
rappelle le le le dernier événement
majeur le l'un des chefs militaires du
Hezbollah pro-iranien qui a été tué par
une frappe israélienne dans le dans le
sud du Liban wisam Jawad altawil euh
est-ce que vous parlez d'un engrenage
guerrier euh à l'œuvre aujourd'hui au
Liban ou est-ce que c'est exagéré alors
tout dépend comment on définit
l'engrenage guerrier ou en tout cas où
est-ce qu'on met le seuil de gravité
dans un engrenage guerrier euh il faut
garder à l'esprit une première chose
c'est que ce n'est pas le premier
responsable militaire à être assassiné
par Israël c'est pas la première fois et
puis il faut pas oublier non plus que
euh au sein de la alors résistance
islamique au Liban parce que c'est comme
ça que s'appelle la partie la partie
armée de l'organisation euh on est
euh tout à fait disposé à payer le prix
euh en l'occurrence éventuellement de
mourir euh pour euh pour pour la cause
donc euh il est prévu de toute façon euh
de remplacer euh un un un responsable
militaire qu t important tombe est
remplacé
non je ne vois pas disons cet assassinat
déclencher quelque chose de réellement
gravissime en tout cas qui nous
amènerait par exemple un dérapage du
style à ce qu'on a pu avoir en 2006 on y
reviendra on réexpliquera ce qui s'est
passé évidemment en 2006 en détail parce
que c'est une date très importante quand
on parle du Liban on y consacrera un
chapitre entier je vous le promets
évidemment David roleros comment le
hzbola si on est là dans le dans le
court terme comment le esbola peut
réagir à cette frappe visant l'un de ses
chefs militaires bah il réagit jusqu'à
présent de manière paramétrée calibrée
il y a une effectivement il est obligé
de réagir à chaque fois qu'il y
a il y a une opération de ce type mais
en même temps il y a le souci de
maintenir quand même un espèce
d'équilibre parce que il souhait pas
rentrer dans un conflit une déflagration
directe l'Iran non plus puisque l'Iran
est derrière donc il a il y a un jeu
instable mais effectivement qui est pour
l'instant proportionné mais mais on peut
constater quand même que au fil des
semaines il y a une incrémentation des
des frappes hein euh c'est et donc ça
montre que la tension quand même sacroit
même si elle est encore calibrée
paramétrée on peut pas être à l'abri
d'un d'un d'un d'un d'un dérapage
incontrôlé c'est pas ce type d'événement
qui va justifier éventuellement le
passage d'une ligne rouge mais mais en
tout cas c'est quand même le signe d'une
extrême tension ouis Armel charier quand
Israël frappe en une semaine le numéro 2
du ramas puis un un un chef militaire
important du du Hezbollah d'abord est-ce
que c'est relativement rare ou pas et
puis ensuite qu'est-ce que ça signifie
c'est ça reste relativement rare surtout
dans la proximité en fait de ce qui
s'est passé et ça signifie en fait que
Israel aujourd'hui comme c'est un pays
qui est en guerre elle a à la fois une
logique qui est une logique sur Gaza
dont on parle régulièrement en disant
non on est maintenant la 3è étape de ce
conflit et que derrière elle a une
logique aussi d'aller chercher les
responsables dans les différents pays et
en les ciblant et avec de l'information
soit qu' elle trouve soit qu' lui est
donné et donc là ça veut dire que vous
avez quand même tous les service de
renseignement israélien qui se sont mis
en place pour savoir où était la le
responsable qui était aujourd'hui dans
le sud de la band lieue de Beyrouth où
était un autre des responsables qui a
été visé qui n'était pas au Liban mais
qui était aussi en Syrie et que grosso
modo c'est la fenêtre de tir d'Israël en
ce moment comme il y a une guerre comme
effectivement les Américains sont
derrière même si ils ne veulent pas une
expansion du conflit même s'ils ont
amené leur porte-avion à côté pour dire
à toute la région on se calme on a mis
des des forces préposées là justement
pour se calmer ça reste quand même le
moment où ils peuvent au nom de la
guerre qu'ils sont en train de mener
dire on a besoin de se défaire d'un tel
d'un tel et d'un tel ou je veux bien je
vous poser la même question à l'un à
l'autre je commence avec vous d'AV rigol
est-ce qu'il y a une fenêtre
d'opportunité pour Benjamin netaniahou
d'essayer de d'affaiblir le Hezbollah en
ce moment ouis al c'est toujours le le
débat d'un ul personnel éventuelou parce
qu'il sait qu'il est sur la Cellette il
sait que quand la guerre avec Casa sera
terminé il va va subir des des enquête
interne doncun considère à tort ou a
raison qu'il est qu' peut profiter de la
situation pour prolonger la guerre voir
entamer un deuxè front puisque tant
qu'il est en guerre effectivement il se
maintient au pouvoir c'est pas exclu que
ça soit une partie de son calcul
personnel mais ça il demeure quand même
qu'il a il y a des fondamentaux c'estàd
qu'il y a la question de de la présence
du hzbollah au-delà du fleuve Litan de
la question de la
résolution non appliquée 1701 depuis
2006 et que depuis le 7 octobre les
Israéliens considèrent que le statut quo
n'est plus tenable ouis et il est de
leur point de vue plus tenable et c'est
là où ça c'est potentiellement dangereux
effectivement il est plus tenable parce
qu'il considère que ce qui le scénario
en plus qui est de du du duob pourrait
se oui et d'autant plus qu'ils ont ils
ont eu accès à des documents
effectivement qui laisse qui laisseraiit
à penser que il y avait bien un scénario
équivalent sur le nord avec la force
radouine justement dont un des chefs
vient d'être éliminé eu a derur votre
avis même question est-ce qu'il y a une
une fenêtre d'opportunité pour Benjamin
nataniaou il est pas le seul à décider
il y a un cabinet de guerre quandême
tout à fait je pense que nataniaou et
son gouvernement ont un problème qui est
que cette idée d'essayer d'affaiblir le
sbà ils l'ont déjà tenté en 2006 à
l'époque ils n'avait pas de front à Gaza
ils avaient absolument mis le maximum de
leur capacité
militaire donc dans dans l'opération il
avaient attiqué massivement par air par
euh par mer et puis sur les derniers
jours donc il y avait une une grande
invasion terrestre du Liban à l'époque
il y avait le gouvernement donc de
George W Bush à l'époque des no
conservateurs hein qui étaient vraiment
derrière euh et puis ça n'a strictement
rien donné donc euh là je doute que vu
le contexte actuel où Israël a besoin de
ne pas se disperser de ne pas perdre la
majorité de ses capacités militaires en
fait du vrai front qui est celui de Gaza
je vois mal comment est-ce que le
gouvernement nataniaou pourrait
vraiment régler le cas Hezbollah ou
disons affaiblir significativement le
eszbollah alors on va faire un peu de
pédagogie maintenant je propose à Tam
tranui de de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau on va détailler un peu expliquer
ce qu'est justement le esbollah
rebonsoir Tam comment est née cette
organisation où est-elle implantée le
hzbolla c'est littéralement le Parti de
Dieu le cousin du Hamas il est notamment
implanté dans la zone Sud Liban c'est
celle de la frontière
libano-israélienne un secteur sousension
depuis plus de 40 ans il est né en
1982 pour résister à l'invasion
israélienne du Liban qui cette année-là
pousse son avancée jusqu'à beyouth pour
combattre l'OLP l'Organisation de
Libération de la Palestine alors c'est à
la fois un parti politique et une milice
islamiste chi qui est lié à l'Iran
l'Iran qui est son principal sponsor il
le finance selon Washington l'Iran lui
apporte plusieurs centaines de millions
de dollars par an il lui a aussi livré
des missiles son emblème d'ailleurs du
hzbollah est toute armé il est vert
couleur de l'islam avec le mot hzbollah
calligraphié et cette lettre qui se
transforme en kalashnikov son armement
étaufé c'est d'ailleurs et bien l'une de
ses forces les experts estiment qu'il
dispose aujourd'hui de 20 à 30000
combattant de 150000 roquettes et le
mouvement revendique depuis 2018
disposer de missilees de haute précision
d'ailleurs il y a régulièrement des tirs
de requettees sur Israël depuis le 7
octobre oui dès le 9 octobre et depuis
et bien le mouvement islamistes lance
quotidiennement des attaques contre
Israël depuis le sud du Liban ce qui
fait craindre un embrasement dans la
région le mouvement aussi appel une
journée de colère au mois d'octobre par
exemple entretenir la colère à l'égard
d'Israël ça a été sa première position
dans cette guerre le 3 novembre dans sa
première prise de parole après le début
du conflit le secrétaire général du
hzbollah nasrala n'appelle pas encore à
la guerre ouverte voyez alors ce qu'il
déclare il dit on craint une escalade
potentielle sur ce front le risque qu'il
se transforme en une guerre à grande
échelle la possibilité que ce front se
transforme en une guerre de grande
ampleur est réaliste et ne peut être
exclu depuis et bien le ton est
largement monté écoutez-le le 3 janvier
dernier après que le numéro 2 du Hamas a
été tué par une frappe israélienne dans
la banlieu sud de
beyouth si l'EM Israël envisage de faire
la guerre au Liban nous nous battrons
sans retenue sans règles sans limites et
sans
restrictions ils savent ce que je veis
dire et je l'ai dit en ouverture de ce
débat depuis l'un des dirigeants du
Hezbollah a également été tué dans une
frappe israen lundi le hasbol annoncé la
mort de l'un de ses dirigeants
effectivement wisam tail c'est un des
haut responsables de la force alradouine
on voit on va voir les images bien aussi
de ses obsèques dans son village où
était rassemblés des centaines de
membres du ba la force Radouan et bien
c'est un commando militaire déployé dans
le sud du Liban pour les Israéliens le
décapiter décapiter cette force est une
priorité car c'est l'unité des forces
spéciales c'est les forces d'élite du
haszbollah la pour mission principale de
lutter contre les tentative d'offensive
israélienne sur le territoire libanais
et d'infiltrer le nord d'Israël pour
cela et bien la force dispose d'un
armement sophistiqué d'hommes entraînés
les sources israéliennes estiment que ce
commando comporte 2000 1500 combattants
quand le hzbola parle lui de 10000 un
chiffre qui est pris avec la plus grande
prudence par les experts on sait pas
vraiment depuis la mort de wisam talil
le hzbollah avé en représail vous l'avez
dit une base militaire dans le nord
d'Israël à l'aide de plusieurs drones
suicides mais Israël indique que cette
attaque n'a fait ni blessé ni dégâts
merci beaucoup Tam aur d' je reviens
vers vous
sur on va dire le degré d'indépendance
du hzbollah par rapport à l'Iran si je
dis le hzbola est une marionnette de
l'Iran est-ce que je caricature ah oui
ouou beaucoup alors la relation entre le
Hezbollah et l'Iran elle est complexe
elle est d'autant plus complexe qu'elle
a évolué au cours du temps lezbollah
c'est maintenant une boutique il y a
plus de 40 ans et alors il y a un
premier une
première je ve dire incompréhension
occidentale vis-à-vis du hzbolah on a
pendant longtemps cru que le hzbolah
avait été créé par l'Iran et en
l'occurrence dans l'optique iranienne
d'exporter la Révolution et cetera en
fait c'est pas céit pas tout à fait vrai
c'est vraiment une création libanaise et
d'ailleurs même
ce qui est assez assez drôle c'est que
l'ayat khinii initialement quand les
Libanais sont venus voir en disant on
voudrait créer justement cette
organisation paramitaire il était contre
il était contre pour deux raisons il a
considéré d'abord que l'armée
israélienne était beaucoup trop forte
pour être vaincue et deuxièmement il
considérait que il ne voulait pas
distraire en fait les forces iraniennes
puisque n'oublions pas en 80 donc on a
le démarrage d'une guerre entre l'Iran
et l'Irak il veut pas être distrait de
ce qu'il a
lui-même sur le feu avec les IR mais
aujourd'hui et lien financi militaire
quel est le degré voilà de le poid de
l'Iran sur l'organisation sur le sur le
plan financier en fait l'aide iranienne
elle va surtout à la partie armée donc à
la Résistance Islamique pas vraiment au
esbola pas vraiment aux institutions
civiles qui ell au contraire ont été
sommés déjà depuis la fin des années 80
par le présidentanan et lui-même de se
débrouiller pour s'autofinancer et le
fait est que lebola aujourd'hui en tant
que réseau d'institutions civile a
beaucoup beaucoup de de de de moyens de
financement divers et variés
à la fois au sein de la société
libanaise dans la diaspora et cetera le
lien en fait après de coopération et de
subordination entre entre le hzbollah et
l'Iran alors il y a ce qu'on appelle
régulièrement ce que les experts
appellent donc traduit littéralement
français c'est le gouvernement du jurist
consulte concept obscur s'il en est en
fait en théorie disons le hzbollah
reconnaît au nom de d'une tradition
chiite à la fois politico enfin
politique et religieuse la subordination
attention pas à l'État iranien et à
l'appareil étatique iranien mais au
Guide de la révolution iranienne
d'accord donc c'est pas le Président
c'est pour autant ça ne veut pas dire
que leesbola ne dispose pas d'une grande
marge de pouvoir continuer
d'argumenter voudrais que la parole se
se distribue un petit peu sur ce thème
là un peu la même question je vous la
pose à l'un et à l'autre peut-être Armel
charier pour commencer voilà que quand
on on voit là depuis 7 octobre les
réactions dub on a tous en êre l'Iran
derrière à quel point c'est vrai d'après
vous la le couplage est réel et c'est
vrai que du coup quand on regarde
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce que israël
va autant frappé du côté du Hezbollah et
donc du Nord forcément c'est parce qu'il
y a aussi un niveau d'énervement de
l'Iran on est obligé aussi de regarder
comme ça en terme de
géopolitique et on voit justement que
l'Iran pour l'instant reste calme et que
le Hezbollah du coup reste calme aussi
euh c'est vrai que fondamentalement
est-ce qu'Israël a besoin d'avoir un
front nord une autre guerre alors
qu'elle est en train de se battre à Gaza
et alors que par exemple utilise
beaucoup de munitions les Américains
doivent leur en fournir et cetera
personne n'a intérêt à avir cette guerre
dans le Nord en revanche effectivement à
poussé les Iraniens à faire l'erreur à
pousser les Iraniens qui sont en train
de monter une
bombe nucléaire à pousser les Iraniens à
réagir là effectivement il y a besoin de
la part d'Israël donc quand elle
s'attaque aujourd'hui au Hezbollah c'est
un peu ça sauf que le hzbollah
aujourd'hui espè espèreè moment donné
avir une il y a une provocation il y a
une provocation quand vous touchez la
Syrie de Bachar al-Assad quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe avec les outils
du côté du Yémen c'est-à-dire tous les
proxis sont un peu excités le Hezbollah
il est forcément beaucoup beaucoup plus
fin parce qu'il a vraiment avec cette
frontière avec Israël une frontière
d'ailleurs qui n'est toujours pas
reconnue puisque les deux pays sont
toujours en guerre et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on voit que le Hezbollah a
une position qui reste plutôt assez
stable c'est-à-dire que nasrala fait des
vindicatifs il y a les prises de
paroleun côé actes mais en même temps il
a des soldats qui là où ça a évolué sont
allés faire la guerre en Syrie donc son
aujourd'hui il a une armée qui est
beaucoup plus établie il a une politique
qui est plus établie et on on voit
effectivement que là tous les jours on
est en train de voir où est
l'exagération et où est la non
exagération David Rigolet rose à quel
point l'Iran calme ou freine le hzbollah
aujourd'hui d'après vous bah le hzbola
c'est un parti libanais donc il y a un
ADL libanais mais il y a aussi
idéologiquement
effectivement une un ADN euh lié à la
République enfin au guide au Guide
suprême donc il est il est à la fois il
est autonome dans sa gestion c'est un
acteur central de chiik Libanais c'est
ce qui fait sa crédibilité sa force et
donc et c'est un joyau en même temps
pour l'Iran c'est l'Iran a pas envie de
sacrifier le hzbolah dans une politique
aventureuse donc c'est ce qui explique
la prudence pour l'instant actuellement
d'ailleurs on peut noter que c'est a été
peu relevé mais nasral a fait une
déclaration à propos de la frontière
justement à la faveur de de la visite de
blinken en faisant un appel du pied en
disant qu'il y aurait peut-être une
opportunité pour pour justement discuter
de l'établissement de la frontière c'est
intéressant compte tenu du contexte
actuel et curieusement assez
paradoxalement il y a une forme de
d'alignement en fait objectif entre la
position américaine qui veut éviter une
déstabilisation régionale un débordement
et le hzbola et l'Iran alors que alors
qu'évidemment la tension est ex me oui
euh je je reviens vers vous Aurélie d'
peut-être sur le poids militaire là
alors la branche armée du sbolla je sais
pas pardon je pouris pas peut-être pas
exactement les les bons termes mais
c'est incomparable en terme de puissance
militaire avec le ramas à Gaza euh vous
dire en terme de troupe capacité
milita c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
puissant lebola alors je oui je pense et
surtout ils sont ils sont beaucoup plus
professionnels et mieux mieux entraînés
h faut pas oublier que leboll a aussi
les années de guerre en en Syrie qui
quand même a permis à ses combattants de
monter en compét
euh j'ai envie dire presque un privilège
que le Hamas n'a pas n'a pas eu en tout
cas pas encore peut-être que là
justement AC ce qui se passe depuis
octobre ça va être un moment dans
l'histoire du Hamas où on va voir des
des voilà des combattants montés en
compétence euh j'ai envie de dire il
faut quand même nuancer cette histoire
de nombre de troupes et de nombre de
roquettes en ce qui concerne lebola donc
comme disait bah votre collègue d'abord
on a absolument aucune aucun chiffre
fiable et puis il faut pas oublier que
il existe au centre du esbola euh une
cellule qui est chargée en mode de
contre-espionnage de faire courir sur
l'organisation elle-même de fausses
rumeurs sur le nombre de requettes le
nombre de troupes où sont voilà cachés
où sont exactement nos
entrepôts de grossir en quelque sorte de
faire cro sont plus puissants qu'il ne
son alors je vais vous donner un exemple
moi les entretiens par exemple que j'ai
pu mener avec des personnes qui sont
chargées de ce travaill là par exemple
céit en 2006 euh voilà tous les mois on
lançait sur le marché de la rumeur des
chiffres différents alors tantôt on
grossissait on a 100000 roquettes le
mois d'après c'est on en a plus que
10000 on en a qui ont des porté à 70 km
d'autres non non on en a la porté à 300
km et cetera parce que on sait que
effectivement comme vous l'avez indiqué
Armel en fait le
mossade tout à fait il est actif au
Liban mais c'est pas nouveau il l'a
toujours il l'a toujours été donc euh le
hzbola c'est aussi qu'une partie de la
population libanaise qui ne le soutient
pas est tout à fait disposé aussi à
faire passer des informations au aux
Israéliens donc il est important ça fait
partie de la stratégie en fait du hbola
pour protéger sa partie militaire de
faire courir de de fausses rumeurs sur
ses capacités sur ses capacités
militaires réelles h alors je voudrais
qu'on revienne effectivement vous avez
commencé à en parler à ce qui s'est
passé en en 2006 donc ça commence par
l'enlèvement de deux soldats israéliens
par le Hezbollah David qu'est-ce qui se
passe ensuite c'est une vraie guerre qui
s'est déroulé à ce moment ça dure 33
jours donc c'est oui c'est une vraie
guerre
effectivement et et d'ailleurs la force
Radwan était partie prenante de ce qui
s'est passé justement de ce qui a
déclenché la guerre en question et elle
se sole par donc elle est elle est
meurtrière des deux côtés hein
d'ailleurs et et les buts de guerre
israéliens sont
partiellement remplie mais effectivement
la situation n'est pas n'est pas soldée
et on arrive à la résolution 1701 qui
fixe résolution des Nations Unies
Nations Unies qui fixe effectivement bah
il y a l'établissement de la finule avec
en principe l'absence de force armées
sur 30 km entre le litanie et et la
frontière chose qui n'a pas été appliqué
et et qui qui est un des problèmes
justement qui est posé aujourd'hui et
qui fait que YAF galant notamment dit
que il y a une solution pour l'instant
ministre de la Défense qui dit que le
mieux ce serait une solution
diplomatique pour
que le hebolah se retire en D du
Litan sinon faut de quoi il y aurait une
option militaire et c'est ce qui
préoccupe les chancellerie parce
qu'effectivement il y a eu le 7 octobre
et et là ça change les données ça change
les données c'est ce qui était toléré
avant ne peut plus l'êre du point de vue
israélien aujourd'hui ouis cette
frontière aujourd'hui encore elle est
pas elle est pas précisément définie
entre il y a des
revendications il y a des revendications
comme ça fait partie de c s de de
conflit gelé hein vous l'avez sur le
Golan avec Israël et avec le Syrie vous
l'avez là sur ce tracé avec les fermes
de Cheba par exemple d'autres chose ça
fait partie de ces endroits finalement
où l'ONU reste présent aussi très
longtemps on se demande toujours
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a des décennies
d'intervention de l'ONU c'est parce
qu'en fait il y a pas d'accord de paix
qui sont qui sont signés donc de
frontières qui sont délimité et c'est
vrai que du coup ça fait que vous avez
des j'ais dire des dans les pays des
excroissances qui sont en train de se
créer le Hezbollah a existé au Liban
parce qu'à un moment donné c'était
l'opposition aussi à Israël et du coup
c'était une partie chiite et qui
existait parce qu'il y avait justement
une façon de pratiquer la guerre par
rapport à Israël de pouvoir réagir s'il
se passait quoi que ce soit c'est une
force qui s'est armée et c'est une force
aujourd'hui en 2023 qui compte
énormément au niveau politique donc
c'est une force aujourd'hui est-ce que
d'ailleurs ça inquiète d'autres
communautés d'autres force politique au
Liban les Libanais eux-mêmes parce que à
la base au Liban vous aviez av Z
toujours un président qui était un
président qui était chrétien vous aviez
les sunnites qui avaient un premier
ministre et vous aviez les chiites qui
avaient le Parlement et aujourd'hui le
Hezbollah pèse tellement lourd que
finalement la politique elle se tourne
vers le hzbollah et c'est là où ça
devient extrêmement important
c'est-à-dire que on peut aussi bien
parler de l'arsenal militaire on peut
aussi bien dire qu'on ne connaît pas le
nombre de militaires qui sont envoyés en
Syrie et cetera mais vous avez un asrala
qui peut avoir un temps un discours
béliqueux mais aujourd'hui il ne l'a pas
et aujourd'hui par exemple quand il faut
sign
des accords sur la frontière en mer
Méditerranée parce que du coup derrière
on va parler des gisements de gaz
nasrala intervient et alors qu'il ne
reconnaît pas la frontière terrestre là
il y a des accords qui sont trouvés
parce que là il s'agit d'avoir
effectivement une économie derrière donc
ça veut dire que ces gens sont devenus
beaucoup plus subtiles ils savent très
bien avoir un regard un regard plus de
chef d'État c'est d'ailleurs ce que ce
dont on a peur c'est ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est peut-être pour ça aussi
que les Israéliens vont le provoquer à
un moment donné pour qu'il fasse et du
coup un un j'allais dire une un geste
qui ne soit plus celui de quelqu'un qui
est avec un état mais qui soit celui
plus d'un milicien en quelque sorte mais
le Hezbollah de 2006 c'est pas le même
que 2023 ou auréie d'ailleurs ce que ce
que j'ai entendu de votre première
intervention sur ce qui s'est passé en
2006 c'est quand même une sorte de
d'échec de de l'armée israélienne les
buts les buts recherchés n'ont pas été
atteints c'est ce que David Grigol rose
a dit d'une autre façon donc ça doit
inciter aujourd'hui tal ou l'État
hébreux en général pas recommencer tout
à fait mais de toute façon on a des deux
côtés hein on a aucun intérêt à à
laisser les choses partir complètement
hors de contrôle en en 2006 quand Israël
lance sa grande offensive donc 33 jours
et 33 nuits nonstop et j'insiste sur les
33 nuits parce que j'étais sous les
bombes en l'occurrence les 33 nuit on a
pas dormi donc le fait est que Israël a
annoncé à la fois à la société j'entends
le gouvernement israélien desouol mer tu
annoncé à la fois sa société et à la
communauté internationale tion deux
choses premièrement l'objectif ça va
être d'exterminer définitivement le
hzbollah ça ça nous ça nous rappelle le
discours actuel sur le voilà et c'est
pour ça que Hassan N a fait du coup sa
comparaison en disant oui les Israéliens
n'ont pas retenu de leçon de 2006 c'est
pas tout à fait exact mais il faisait en
l'occurrence allusion à ça donc on
extermine définitivement et complètement
le hbola deuxième chose on va récupérer
nos soldats israéliens donc enlevés par
le hbola de manière inconditionnel et
puis 33 jours et 33 nuits ah oui point
important Israël promet de réaliser tout
cela en une maximum 33 jours 33 nuits
plus tard les soldats israelliens sont
parevenus et non seulement le hbolla n'a
pas été exterminé mais en fait d'une
manière parce qu'il y a aussi une
dimension de guerre psychologique qui
s'est installé en 2006 qui était très
net où le hzbollah pour provoquer aussi
les Israéliens en tout cas pour faire
passer le message aux israélien que
décidément vos bombardements ne
fonctionnent
pas le hzbola a augmenté la cadence de
ses tirs semaines après semaine on é on
est passé de 120 au but par jour à
350 requête durant les les derniers
jours du conflit pour bien faire
comprendre aux Israéliens ça ce que vous
faites ne sert à rien fin de la guerre
on appelle les troupe il y a pas un seul
au cadre du hzbollah ou même cadre
intermédiaire qui manque à l'appel donc
par rapport aux objectifs annoncés
d'Israël oui effectivement c'est un
échec pour autant pour autant le hbol a
quand même retenu une leçon qui est
finalement on ne sait jamais comment
est-ce que les Israéliens peuvent réagir
parce que CIT pas la première fois que
le hzbollah voilà menait une une prise
d'otage et les Israéliens habituellement
acceptaient la négociation via
intermédiation allemande et puis on
s'échangeit entre prisonniers dépouill
de soldats dépouilles de combattants
sauf que là Israël a dit non cette
fois-ci cette fois-ci on lance on lance
l'offensive et à niveau complè in
offensive israélienne peut aussi calmer
le hbola j'entend j'entends votre votre
argument alors c'est c'est passionnant
parce que là depuis que le débat a
commencé les uns et les autres nous
dites finalement le risque du du de
d'une escalade ou que d'une contagion de
cette cette guerre au Liban est
relativement faible pourtant quand on
écoute les leaders et là vraiment vous
nous l'avez dit une différence entre le
verbal et les actes qui sont commis on
peut penser vraiment différemment on va
justement réécouter à la fois Hassad
nasrala et Benjamin netanahou 2 janvier
je rappelle les faits pour ceux qui nous
ont rejoint en cours de de débat numéro
2 du Hamas qui est tué par une frappe
israélienne on est au sud de berou Fiè
du hzbollah 3 jours plus tard Hassan
nasrala le chef du hzbolah menace c'est
un autre extrait dans le même cadre que
ce qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure
regardez
cette frappe ne restera pas sans réponse
elle ne passera pas sans être
punie la est
inéuctable la suite se passera désormais
sur le champ de bataille le champ de
bataille
répondra le champ de bataille n'attend
pas et donc de jours plus tard benamin
net lui
répond je recomme d'endre ce que a déjà
appris ces derniers mois aucun
terroriste n'est à l'abri nous sommes
déterminés à défendre nos civils et à
permettre aux habitants du nord de
rentrer chez eux en toute sécurité il
s'agit d'un objectif national que nous
partageons tous et nous travaillons de
manière responsable pour l'atteindre si
nous le pouvons nous le ferons par la
voie diplomatique sinon nous agirons par
d'autres
moyens David rigolerose donc on est quoi
ils s'adressent à leurs opinions publiqu
respectives en quelque sorte même si on
peut difficilement compar les deux
organisations oui non mais c'est
incontestable il y a il y a
effectivement des éléments de langage
qui sont destinés en partie à leur
opinion publique et puis et puis
justement pour montrer que au niveau
régional on est on est dans un rapport
de force qui s'exprime à travers ce type
de déclaration mais il faut jamais
exclure quand même le risque de dérapage
hein euh on dit on dit effectivement de
ligne rouge ce serait quoi une ligne
rouge là pour que malheureusement ça
justement on la connait pasou on la il y
en a certaines ement une euh et
d'ailleurs il y a eu plusieurs
déclarations notamment du du numéro 2 de
du du Hezbollah qui a dit qu'il y avait
il y avait il y avait des liges rouges
mais elles ont pas été explicité donc ça
entretient c'est aussi la dision nous on
les connaî pas est-ce que les les les
Israéliens les service secret israélien
connaissent on n'est jamais sûr de la
ligne rouge de l'autre hein c'est le
problème et donc ça entretient le
principe de la dissuasion aussi ce
principe d'incertitude mais mais elles
existent elles existent effectivement et
et donc on peut jamais exclure cette
possibilité justement pour éviter que il
y ait un embrasement régional arm
charier est-ce que Israël cible aussi
Hassan naserala puis qu'on on a vu qu'il
avait la
capacité d'éliminer un certain nombre de
de chef important du hzbolah ou
auparavant du ramas alors je ne suis pas
dans les secrets israéliens voilàe
j'aurais poser la question différemment
est-ce que ça c'est une ligne rouge
voyez dire ça pe ça semble un peu inv
vraisemblable parce qu'on sait que dans
ces cas là pour le coup ça sera l'acte
qui déclenchera quelque chose là ça ne
pourra pas rester impuni euh c'est pour
ça qu'après on reste quand même on
essaie de rester un peu optimiste mais
on est quand même dans un principe de
guerre c'estàdire que quand vous parliez
du dérappage oui chaque fois qu'on relit
des listes des livres d'histoire c'est
une accumulation de petits fait comme ça
qui sont allés la ligne rouge telle
qu'on l'entendait c'était quoi c'était
que Israël fasse des frappes dans la
profondeur au Liban ça ça pouit être une
première ligne rouge que ça tue des
soldats du Hezbollah que ça tue des
civils ça pouvait être une rouge que à
un moment donné il y a un tir dans la
banlieu sud de Beyrouth ça ça pvit être
une liille rouge voyez c'est nous on est
toujours dans cette observation là puis
finalement à Cha on voit et c'est pour
ça qu'on dit à un moment donné il y a
effectivement des directives nasral là
je pense que effectivement là ça
nécessiterit d'avoir quelque chose
unefin y compris de la part des Iraniens
d'avoir parce qu'il faut bien imaginer
que derrière l'Iran arme aussi donne des
missiles donneent des capacités vous
êtes quand même dans cette dans cette
logique là votre avis làdessus puis que
vous n disz tout à l'heure finalement
quand une tête du hebollah tombe une
autre une autre se se présente c'est
prévu toutit tout à fait moi je voudrais
avec votre permission je vrais justement
compléter en fait les propos de mes deux
petits camarades il y a quand même une
une dimension un peu particulière dans
dans ce conflit par rapport à ce qu'on a
habituellement entre le hzbolla et et
Israël c'est que ce conflit il n'est pas
Libano centré et que il faut garder à
l'esprit que le Hezbollah certes il a il
a c'est c'est une relation qui peut être
rapproché avec le Hamas mais il ne faut
pas
sous-estimer le passé voir le passif qui
existe aussi entre les Libanais et les
Palestiniens il y a une grande
différence entre soutenir dans l'absolu
sur le plan moral la cause palestinienne
ça c'est valable pour les dans une gu
tot pour prêt absolument à démolir le
Liban pour les beaux yeux des
Palestiniens les les Palestiniens n'ont
pas laissé que des bons souvenirs aux
Libanais et en particulier au chit du
Liban notamment dans les années 70 après
Septembre noir et jusqu'à donc leur
évacuation en 82 en tout cas
l'évacuation de l'OLP de pas loin de
300000 combattants palestiniens de
beyouth faut pas oublier que les
Palestiniens en l'occurrence avaient
établi un État dans l'État au sud du
Liban qui est chiite et les premières
victimes de cet État dans l'État qui
ceux qui l'ont très mal vécu c'était
c'était des Libanais chites donc autant
à la limite on a une population
libanaise même une communauté ch qui
serait capable d'encaisser beaucoup de
choses de la part d'Israël même des
bombardements massifs si vraiment Israël
était en mode le centre du problème
c'est le Liban et je tape le Liban mais
pas pour pas pour la Palestine pour
inéressant David rigolerose est-ce que
ce que vient de nous dire auré daer ça
vaut aussi pour les autres pays de la
région vous voyez ce que je veux dire
jusqu'où est-on prêt à aller dans dans
dans un conflit pour les Palestiniens
alors il y a il y a les opinions
publiques ce qu'on appelle la rue arabe
entre guillemets hein qui est c'est un
peu de manière un peu caricaturale
d'ailleurs et puis et puis il y a les
les milices euh c'est pas les états
c'est là où c'est on est dans une forme
de guerre hybride assez largement quand
quand vous évoquez les autres pays bah
il va y avoir les milices pro-iranienn
en
Syrie les milices lesabist et Milic
aussi pro-iranienne en Irak qui qui tape
justement sur la base américaine parce
que tout ça est un jeu de ping-pong il y
a les routi bien sûénit les rebelles
yénites canal de su il est quasiment il
est quasiment effectivement c'est assez
significatif pour les Houtis il y a
toujours une tradition très de soutien
très fort auprès des Palestiniens de la
part des yemménites donc c'est pas
uniquement j'allais dire instrumental
mais mais il faut se garder de de voir
une une solidarité des états parce qu'on
est pas on n'est pas dans cette logique
là les États sont travaillés de de
l'Intérieur donc il y a il y a des
effets effectivement régionaux euh qui
s'articulent les uns aux autres mais
mais et en l'occurrence pour pour
effectivement compléter ce que ce qui
était dit sur le les relations entre le
Hamas et le hbola aujourd'hui le nasrala
on veut he au frères sin noir du ramas
parce que d'abord ils ont pas été
prévenus du déclenchement de l'offensive
ensuite il y a des éléments qui ont
fuité qui ont inventé un scénario qui
aurait pu être développé dans le Nord et
puis et puis il faut rappeler que le
ramas c'est un mouvement d'obédiance
sunite c'est pas un mouvement chite
alors donc il est intégré à l'arc de la
résistance antiisraël mais c'est pas du
tout le même solidarité qui pourrait y
avoir éventuellement avec les outils ou
ou d'autres alors il y a un dernier
chapitre qu'on ouvre tout de suite que
j'ouvre tout de suite dans ce débat sur
les les efforts diplomatiques on va dire
ça comme ça Mathieu je commence avec
vous sur le la France est-ce que la
France peut encore jouer un rôle pour
éviter un embrasement de du Liban et de
la région alors sur sur le plan
militaire elle joue déjà un rôle d'une
certaine manière puisqu'on rappelle que
les soldats français forment le premier
contingent de environ 700 soldats sur
10000 de la force intérimaire des
Nations Unies au Liban la finulle dont
on parlait tout à l'heure installé dans
le sud du pays et qui joue aujourd'hui
un rôle de contrôle ou de surveillance
le long de cette fameuse ligne bleue
cette frontière que qui n'est pas
officiel entre l'État hébreu et et le
Liban c'est d'ailleurs la France qui
propose traditionnellement au vote à
l'ONU la prorogation du mandat de cette
fameuse finule chaque année à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
sur le plan militaire toujours
Paris a régulièrement fourni une aide
aux forces armées libanaises cette
fois-ci mais ce qui est un geste
éminemment politique pour garantir une
forme de de de stabilité à la fois au
Liban et et dans la région alors ça
c'est le côté militaire sur le plan
diplomatique alors sur le plan
diplomatique c'est une autre affaire car
l'étoile de la France a P au Liban comme
dans le reste de la région alors elle
reste un membbr euh de poids du groupe
des 5 vous savez l'Égypte le Qatar
l'Arabie Saoudite les États-Unis éit un
groupe qui était conçu pour sortir le
Liban de l'impasse et surtout faire
contre-poids aussi à l'Iran sur la scène
internationale mais depuis le 7 octobre
Paris a dépêché à plusieurs reprises sa
ministre des Affaires étrangères son
ministre de la Défense et même un
émissaire spécial du Président de la
République le Haut Représentant du
président de la République pour le Liban
qui est jean-iv audrian ancien ministre
des Affaires étrangères tous porteurs du
même message de mise en garde contre les
risques d'escalade et même s'ils sont
reçus par tous les officiels ben on a
pas l'impression que la voix de la
France porte forcément très loin parce
que la France qui était un interlocuteur
traditionnel je dire privilégié du Liban
depuis la fin du protectorat ben sa voix
porte beaucoup moins aujourd'hui en
particulier pour deux raisons depuis
2020 vous souvenez l'année de
l'explosion du port de berout Emmanuel
Macron qui arrive comme un sauveur il
crée un immense espoir et puis bah il se
passe pas grand-chose pour ainsi dire
sinon rien c'est pas que de sa faute he
pas il soulève un espoir qui n'est pas
CELI des fait notamment il continue de
de morigène la la la la classe politique
libanaise mais il continue de de
d'essayer de daler avec elle autre
événement c'est surtout l'aspect
politique parce que Armel l'a rappé tout
à l'heure on a une crise une impasse
politique au li en ce moment le pouvoir
il serait parti entre on a dit les
chrétiens maronid pour la présidence de
la République et là il se trouve que la
présidence de la République elle est
vacante et que il y a des tentatives la
France soutient et que la France a
soutenu un très curieux candidat euh
cette année qui était Sliman frangier
qui est le candidat du hzbollah du parti
cheit Amal donc de l'Iran et cétait pas
le favori elle l'a pas soutenu
officiellement mais c'était le candidat
qu'elle poussait de façon très
pragmatique et très Réal politique ce
qui a déçu beaucoup de Libanais
évidemment qui ne se reconnaissent pas
dans cette faction merci Mathieu ça
c'est pour la France je voudrais on a
entendu ant blincen dans le le le
reportage tout à l'heure donc on va pas
le réécouter mais je vrais qu'on écoute
plutôt tiens le ha
l'Union européenne pour les affaires
étrangères la politique de sécurité
Joseph Borel c'est toujours le même
discours attention à
l'escalade il est impératif d'éviter une
escalade régionale au
MoyenOrient il est absolument nécessaire
d'éviter que le Liban ne soit entraîné
dans un conflit régional c'est la
dernière chose dont le Liban a besoin
il nous reste quelques minutes dans ce
débat peut-être autour du mot piège
est-ce que voilà le l'Union européenne
mais aussi les États-Unis parlons
peut-être plus des États-Unis Ahmed
charier se sent piégé de plus en plus
par ce qui est en train de se passer
dans la région je pense que ce qui est
compliqué pour eux c'est que ils ne
peuvent absolument pas lâcher Israël qui
est aujourd'hui leur seul allié au
Moyen-Orient et que donc du coup ils
font tous les efforts pour Israël
aujourd'hui on le voit d'ailleurs parce
que duucraine on payer le prix et qu'en
même temps ils savent à quel point ce
Moyen-Orient est explosif et qu'en plus
là leurs intérêts sont pas servis dans
le sens où pendant qu'on est en train de
se parler vous avez aussi des attaques
de plus en plus importantes sur les
soldats américains qui sont stationnés
en Irak et qui sont stationnés en Syrie
enfin du coup il y a une recrudescence
avec les rebelles outils il y a aussi le
commerce à un moment donné qui prend un
coup dans toute cette zonel ce qui n'est
avantage strictement personne euh les
Américains quelque part sur le Liban
savent très trs bien que c'est un pays
qui aujourd'hui est complètement laminé
par la corruption par le fait que c'est
les chefs de guerre des années 70 80 qui
tiennent encore les rennes et que donc
du coup CIT pas réparti sur la société
civile euh alors il n'a pas d'action
directe la France a eu des actions plus
directes quand le président s'est
annoncé et cetera même si concrètement
derrière ça n'a pas été mais on attend
d'avoir à un moment donné quelque chose
qui émerge de ce de ce Liban qui
s'appauvrit nonstop qui a cet espoir
dans ses poches de gaz qu'il a trouvé en
mer Méditerranée mais en dehors de ça on
est quand même dans un pays qui
s'appauvrit comme rarement et donc du
coup c'est vrai que ils savent bien que
tout ça n'est pas n'est pas l'apanage
d'une nouvelle guerre et ça rend les
choses très compliqué en même temps vous
avez une société libanaise qui elle
continue d'être active vous avez par
exemple eu les vacances là de fin
d'année de Noël de réveillon et vous
avez des Libanais qui sont rentrés chez
eux à Beyrouth qui ont fait la fête
parce que ils savent que leur pays est
dans cet état-là depuis tellement
longtemps depuis tellement des décennies
qu'il faut continuer mais c'est vrai que
ça donne une juste une image qui montre
la complexité de la situation David
Rigolet rose le dispositif militaire
américain dans la région il est en train
d'évoluer c'est ça oui et c'est pas
déconnecter de ce des pressions
américaines sur Israël puisque les
Américains ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
éloigner le
porte-avion geral Ford qui croisait au
large justement pour pas que les
Israéliens potentiellement aient une
assurance tout risque S se lançait dans
une opération militaire c'est aussi un
message subliminal à Benjamin
netaniaahou alors il y a le porte-avion
etenow qui est en dans le golf d'Aden
qui justement est partie prenante de de
la sécurité maritime dans cette région
mais il est pas tout près et donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même un message
hein c'est une manière de dire n'oubliez
pas que on est quand même un soutien
indispensable mais ce déploiement c'est
il était dissuasif et le message il
était à destination de l'Iran donc
initialement le déplo
fautle as après le 7 octobre c'était
amené effectivement pour avoir la
garantie que le hzbollah
n'interviendrait pas ou n'ouvrirait pas
un deuxième front donc c'est un message
évidemment inérant mais à partir du
moment où aujourd'hui il y a l'idée de
justement d'éviter une logique
escalatoire éventuellement que de que
Israël ne s'engage pas justement dans
une opération comme beaucoup de discours
de le laisse entendre c'est une manière
de leur dire faites attention parce que
effectivement cette gar là elle est
évolutive h merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat qui
était passionnant merci à toutes et à
tous de votre ah oui j'oubliais de
rappeler le titre de votre livre on l'a
vu s'afficher le hbola mobilisation et
pouvoir merci encore d'avoir participé à
l'émission merci à toutes et à tous de
votre fidélité demain c'est Mathieu
croissant d'au qui qui vient à ma place
qui prend les reenes avec mais c'est un
grand plaisir de vous laisser le de vous
laisser le SI de de présentateur on se
retrouve donc lundi et puis notez que
l'invité de la matinale de public sénna
ce sera manuel bonpard le coordinateur
de la France insoumise face à riane
moncini c'est à 8h du matin belle soirée
à toutes et à
[Musique]
tous